à casimir toutes nos corps et sont
absurdes j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour toi
mais vous mettez également très
sympathique a bien casimir ton amitié me
réjouis je suis ravi qu'on soit un
copain
enfin casimir pas parce que je t'offre
mon amitié ne doit dépasser les limites
bon on a leur amitié a des limites on
s'est déjà nettement moins intéressant
était-ce mire bonjour joly excusez-moi
l'instant mon cher à long mais je t'en
prie que se passe-t-il là tu avais
promis à françois d'aller ramasser les
vieux papiers dans le petit bois
aujourd'hui enfin se fait pas on ne
jette pas les papiers dans le petit bois
tu as raison mais en attendant existants
il faut les ramasser tu avais premier de
le faire aujourd'hui mais ça tombe très
mal je devais justement aller chez ma
tante adélaïde qui m'a préparé une glace
aux anchois avec des câpres
écoutant qui tuera plus tard
je lui fais tu as une pièce de monnaie
kouyate en quatre ans voilà merci je te
la rend tout à l'heure là je te fais
confiance à ceux du snav et jouer à pile
ou face à as oui bien sûr c'est très
facile on lance une pièce ont l'air
lorsqu'elle retombe si on voit le
chiffre le nombre c'est à dire ce qui
donne la valeur de la pièce et bien
c'est pile mais si on voit le dessin est
le plus souvent c'est un visage et bien
c'est face bon alors je vous propose une
partie de pile ou face à une pourquoi
pas quel est l'enjeu l'enjeu est bien ce
soir à aller pour celui qui perd à les
ramasser les papiers dans le petit bois
ramassé les peuples oui bon je suis
d'accord alors c'est très simple casimir
pile je gagne face tu perds d'accord tu
en es lancer la pièce vous même très
bien non je pose la can
[Musique]
pile je gagne haut la main à 100 ne
l'attendait au jeu quand vous avez mal
lancer la pièce n'ai rien vu
casimir de ce tri chez ce n'est pas bien
du tout enfin tu as une amie je veux
bien recommencer à l'heure pile je gagne
face tu perds d'accord jake en vient
à face tu perds encore bonjour j'ai
vraiment pas de chance tu vas casimir
aller de cette lettre parce que c'est
nouveau travail allez au revoir casimir
l'argent il ramasse et tous les papiers
dans le petit mois
pile il gagne en face je perds
mais avec ce système là je ne pouvais
jamais gagné ça allons monsieur des
snobs vous avez triché
richard tricheurs
que se passe-t-il ici d'un côté casimir
120 en hurlant et toi julie du est prise
d'un accès de fous rires
c'est casimir qui voulait faire ramasser
les papiers du petit bois à monsieur dit
stop alors il va proposer une partie de
pile ou face et il eut à glee si c'est
pile je gagne et si c'est face tu perds
alors le porho quasi bien ne pouvait pas
gagner et casimir ne s'est rendu compte
de rien
après seulement il s'est rendu compte qu
est-ce qui s'est débattue et c'est pour
ça qu'il est parti à sa poursuite
de toute façon casimir et monsieur du
snob sont aussi tricheurs l'inclure pour
cirque annuel facteurs oui mais tout ça
moi ça n'arrange pas mes affaires non je
voulais faire un jeu avec les enfants
justement la présence de casimir mettait
indispensable j'ai l'impression que tu
ne le reverra pas de sitôt qu'est ce que
je vais pouvoir faire faire aux enfants
et bien croûte si tous leurs chantait la
chanson il serait ravi tu crois bien sûr
pour ben d'accord j'ai chanté la chanson
des enfants venez françois va vous
chanter sa chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savent c'est ce que je voudrais
l'infinie vraiment petit ou très grand
les fourmis les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
jeu
[Musique]
on explique que ses mystères je voudrais
être très savants que d'être le secret
des choses y at-il vraiment quelque part
des éléphants risquent l tat deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des experts il voit
ton parfois des lions d
s'ils gagnent les moineaux les cocos et
les marches tout près
les canards
[Musique]
la haute cour et les dauphins l'est
parce qu'ils sont de vrais mammifères
son
c'est
comme des poissons dans r je voudrais
être très sale en connaître le secret
des chaudières y at-il vraiment quelque
part des éléphants rescate deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des épaules ils
voient qu'on parle pas des lions des
hommes séguin
très
c'est ce que je voudrais
[Musique]
très j'aime
et
[Musique]
baa